all right joining us now
is the attorney for president trump
david shone for this impeachment
i call it the shift show charade um
we've been friends a long time david i
loved your arguments i loved your
passion i thought it started it's sort
of like
a lot of free associating in the
beginning and i'm not i'm i'm not
attacking your partner i don't i don't
know him
at all uh but i liked i like
focused arguments and i particularly
liked you actually ran
tape um of of the democrats pointing out
the obvious that oh news has changed
quite a bit since the snap impeachment
yeah it's uh i think this is a very very
very painful and wrong process for the
country
it's as you said earlier in your show
it's very easy to stand up and show
spliced and manufactured films literally
you know the democrats the house
managers
apparently hired a large uh movie
company and a large law firm
to put together this thing it's just
it's a matter of tricking the american
people
to play as if the rioting was going on
in real time
with the speech what's the purpose of
that why do we want to trick the
american people
and at least they have great
entertainment value people are glued to
you know a movie that's made
professionally like that
but that's not going to advance the
causes any cause of good in the country
the constitutional issue jurisdiction
let's go over that
and why this is not constitutional yeah
there's so many reasons why it's not
constitutional it's funny you know that
dem
the house managers got up and said such
a clear question even their people say
it's a close call at best but it's
common sense
nobody thinks of using the impeachment
process for anything other than
removing a civil official from office
we have courts if you want to have an
investigation you want to prosecute
someone something like that
we have the courts for that that's not
what an impeachment is for
but you know we talked about the
language uh in the in the uh
constitution today
that sort of thing it's just it's to me
it's it's absolutely nonsense
the president is no longer the president
right now and
uh he's a a person who can't be removed
from office he's a private citizen
this is what our founding father is very
much against
having a legislative body try a private
citizen think about it
he doesn't get any of the benefits or
safeguards that our constitution
provides for someone who has an actual
trial
they put in that vid that videotape
would never go into evidence any in any
court in the world
today it's a splice tape showing what
they want to show
it's pretty profound to me that
the media is now acknowledging uh we
have law enforcement the fbi
acknowledging
uh we have court documents acknowledging
we have ocasio-cortez the congresswoman
acknowledging
all these people now discussing how
in fact this was all pre-planned well
how do you make
the argument that at a rally the words
of the president
to peacefully and patriotically march to
the capitol so your voices are heard
how do you make the argument that that
incited an insurrection
when in fact it was all planned out
apparently ahead of time according to
all of these varying sources now
yeah even taking the position that that
speech inciting an insurrection
is as dangerous as i can imagine in the
free speech area
it would absolutely chill passionate
political speech
um i think one of your other guests
maybe mr trump jr uh
said it best that uh you know compared
to other rhetoric you hear this was
mild if you really read the speech and
watch it um
he calls for uh when he uses the word
fight it's in the context of a
legislator fighting
or something like that it's a it's a
really setting a horrible
message to people i understand they
don't like donald trump
on that side of the aisle well he has
you know half the country who loves him
i would say to you probably that if he
had 74 75 million
million voters they voted for him
because they love donald trump i don't
know that many other candidates can say
that many
people may have voted because they
didn't want donald trump for the other
candidate but
he has a real following um he's a
passionate person
and it's setting a very dangerous and
wrong message
and it's a it's a hoax i'm sorry to say
if we apply the democratic standards for
how they define incitement and
insurrection
well what if we applied it as we started
our monologue tonight to the words of
joe biden kamala harris chuck schumer
nancy pelosi maxine waters and
a whole host of others if that same
standards
is applied do they not all deserve
impeachment too
by the way i don't agree with it but if
you use their standard it seems if
you're somewhat intellectually honest
you'd have to say they deserve
impeachment
yeah i would say if you know listen if
they tried to impeach them i would say
that also as an abuse
was an abuse of the impeachment process
but your point is
they're using rhetoric that's justice
inflammatory or more so
the problem is they don't really have
followers you know they're dedicated
followers
and so you know when they give their
speeches but this speech
i think right now you really are finding
out about the pre-planning
and i'm afraid they're going to back off
that investigation because maybe you
know
so many people want to tie it to donald
trump there's nothing they showed today
and in any way ties us to donald trump
that it's just a silly argument it's not
tied to donald trump
or his speech whatsoever so what they're
doing now a bit is going about well you
see it's not just that speech
he's been you know inciting people and
flaming people no he's been trying
rousing the american public to drain the
swamp whatever they call it
on his side to make a difference in this
country
that's what political speech is about
there's a lot of criticism of the
opening not your part in particular
um it seemed to be free associating
extemporaneous
uh somewhat meandering
will the rest of this process because
you're going to be out as i understand
it friday and saturday
will will this be more focused and will
be more prepared and
are there other people that some
conservatives called me and said
well we need somebody harder hitting
here
well the fellow who you say did the
opening today has his law firm there
there seems to be very capable people
i'm sure today he hadn't planned on
going and uh
so i'm sure that they'll be very well
prepared in the future
and do a great job in the case there's a
lot to say and i know they feel very
strongly
about fighting against what they're
seeing all right david good job today
thank you so much for sharing it with us
we appreciate